je suis obligé de remettre cette vidéo
non je les dis ce matin j'ai dit je veux
remettre attention à la marche
vous n'avez pas vu c'est vous c'est déjà
tu voulais être une star avec 14 ans
jusque là qu'on a pris même des extraits
toi on a des images de toits c'est notre
notre ami jean luc reichmann et met on
entre et moi je ne m'en lasse pas ne
pensez pas que l'entrée pardon mais
puisque on la revoit autant que les gens
analysent les bonnes choses c'est que
c'est la gueule la gueule et terrible
audrey de la gueule à cette époque donc
j'avais des bagues et le dentiste pour
me faire plaisir m'avait dit je te les
enlève au fur et à mesure comme ça tu en
a de moins en moins et à ce moment là de
ma vie mon reste 3 je vous laisse
regarder
c'est une mairie mais s'est il ya de
plus en plus de gens qui mettent des mac
même et risma pour rien c'est vrai dans
certains pays bas fin non non ça c'est
la bijouterie salariés après quoi elle a
vu les bacs ces sites de richesses et
les deux balasar n a pas vraiment merci
gucci group à mentir et sioniste
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît on n'a pas pas d'où les
ailes à 14 ans au caire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
noël c'est bien même c'est très embêtant
d'être tout le temps séparés des grands
c'est tout le temps il ya une table pour
les grands oui et une table pour les
petits oui mais toi tu te situes houle
moi je me situe un peu entre les deux ah
oui donc tu manges martin s'est marié
vit là je comprends je compose du combo
et oui quand on est quel âge as-tu kevin
14 ans tuée à 14 heures à oui donc
bientôt de 15 ans mais tu es très rapide
qui sait vous le gard on dirait on
dirait un surveillant alors mais c'est à
dire il a directeur 26 ans mon frère
ouais ouais non mais il était
sympathique je te jure que j'étais
tellement heureux d'être là ben ouais je
me suis pas gardé dans la glace avant
d'y aller quoi ta venue du penneteau est
encore mieux c'est vrai quoi quoi encore
il est maquillée maintenant il ya 18 ans
c'est en 2009 je m'en souviens j'étais
présent pour animer ce moment avec
alessandra sublet et je te les dickens
ce jour là j'ai su que tel est une mine
non omstar c'était sur le téléthon oui
et c'est vrai que il sait qu elle qui
voulait absolument être là pour le
téléthon pour le téléthon il démarré et
il disait voilà j'ai envie de faire
marrer les gens pour le téléthon ils
étaient venus ils avaient fait un sketch
j'animais une tranche sur le téléthon et
il avait été exceptionnel et ce jour là
je m'en rappelle j'étais sorti j'avais
dit ça va être une énorme star regarde
je vois qu'il ya du monde c'est cool je
vois qu'il ya beaucoup de jeunes c'est
cool ça va les jeunes
je vois que des vieux aussi c'est cool
oui mais c'est vrai qu'on est ça aussi
c'est un truc qui vous énerve grave vous
les adultes le fait que nous les jeunes
on est un peu le pantalon baissé vers
vous avez une blague pour ça une black
cabs une blague d'adultes vous dites oh
là là on dirait qu'il a fait caca dans
son pantalon
ouais mais les nuls cette blague sans
déconner les pouilles
c'est normal le fait que nous les jeunes
on a un peu le pantalon mais si regardez
à l'époque les années 80 un peu au
dessus de la taille night fever les
années 2000 à la taille normal que 2009
bonsoy quoi ça n est franchement ça
m'étonnerait pas qu'en 2030 soit tous
comme ça et je vous jure il était il a
été exceptionnel je suis très content
que tu sois là on a c'est quand même
intéressant qu'on revoie ton visage sans
barreaux merci choqué est ce qu'on peut
en voir les voeux stoeckel s'il vous
plaît dans ce serait vraiment un
hérisson décès des jeunes années
j'adore mais c'est ça qu'on veut c'est
du cheveu comme ça c'est dû sauver des
vies et à une petite carrière aussi sur
youtube ou six dans une vidéo qu'on a
particulièrement aimé cette vidéo
hommage au roi lyon ce que tu te
rappelles de ça j'aime aussi être
boissons gazéifiées alors anges à nos
messages et fait ça j'avais 15 ans à le
dédier au monde toutes les images
dossier dès le début c'est un beau petit
doigt alors il faut savoir un truc c'est
que c'est pour une marque donc de
boisson bien sûr qu'on ne citera pas
d'accord mais je vous le dit son nom de
famille c'est diallo
voilà deux machines à sous de suite
c'est une marque de boisson concon
citera pas un luxe et fanta et
effectivement juste important de savoir
il avait lancé un appel sur internet à
l'époque oui dit si vous êtes un jeune
comédien jeunes créateurs n'hésitez pas
à faire vos pubs et la meilleure pub
quand on la prendra il se trouve qu'ils
n'ont jamais pris ma pub ils ont pris
quelqu'un doute un jour là sauf qu'après
la notoriété venant quelques années à
dire certes ils n'ont remis par les
chasseurs
bon de regarder les gars faut passer à
la caisse a alors regardé
[Musique]
là bas ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]